l'interview de l'ENA pour brut ça va
être exceptionnel
[Musique]
salut les nains bonjour Rémy bonjour
brut comment ça va ça va très bien et
vous bon ça va comment lundi matin c'est
un peu dur mais ça va le lundi matin
j'adore le lundi j'adore le lundi parce
que tout le monde déteste le lundi du
coup j'ai envie de lui donner du love
c'est comme le jaune c'est devenu ma
couleur préférée parce que personne mais
moi j'aime le rouge j'aime le bleu
maintenant et mon jaune et mon lundi on
se met un petit peu à contre-courant
parfois
bon on va essayer de se mettre bien tout
doucement parce que l'interview on est
parti pour à peu près une heure de
conversation ou une heure tu penses que
je vais faire chier les gens moi je
pense pas je pense pas au contraire elle
est tellement de choses à évoquer ça va
être passionnant je suis navré pour tous
ceux qui vont regarder cette vidéo
on a tout là donc ça il y a plein de
choses et l'idée c'est d'y aller en
douceur avec des questions un peu ce
qu'on appelle ping-pong ping pong voilà
donc c'est voilà ce je t'envoie la balle
tu me la renvoie voilà entre nous deux
vu la distance on pourrait la mettre
j'ai fait ping-pong au bac de sport donc
mais du coup bah voilà la petite
première question c'est quoi un peu ton
mood du moment
mood du moment encore un peu en gueule
de bois du Nouvel An mélanger a beaucoup
d'ambition et d'envies pour cette année
mélanger à un relâchement de pression
parce que c'est ma spécialité c'est de
me mettre constamment la pression et
cette année j'ai décidé de chier la
musique que tu écoutes le plus en ce
moment
c'est une vieille dame j'écoute Marvin
Gaye je sais pas ce qui se passe dans
les Spotify du moment mais j'ai une
playlist j'en ai un peu honte parfois la
plus grande qualité
je crois qu'une personne sympatoche
gentille organisé allez j'en fais plein
défaut
très dissipé gros manque de
concentration
complètement anxieuse constamment semer
la pression
peuvent créer un trou noir et embarquer
tous ses potes avec mais toujours avec
le sourire toujours avec le sommet la
plus grande peur dans ta vie plus grande
peur
elle horrible mais c'est de perdre un
proche enfin je pense que c'est celle de
tout le monde on a appris il y a les
serpents mais ton plus grand regret
un plus grand regret tu sais quoi on
aime bien dire non j'ai pas de regret
tout mais il y a des fois où je le matin
je me réveille et je regrette un peu de
des choses de tequila donc là c'est ceux
du nouvel an
le maximum de temps que tu as pu
déconnecter des réseaux sociaux
maximum de temps bah quand ma mère me
confisquait mon téléphone quand j'avais
des mauvaises notes et sinon plus
récemment pendant 12 jours quand je suis
partie faire le Kilimandjaro avec mon
chéri c'est tu peux avoir ton téléphone
il est là mais tu n'as absolument aucune
barre de réseau ni quoi que ce soit et
il fait tellement froid que le téléphone
s'éteint je connais l'iPhone quand il
fait genre 3 degrés il commence à
s'éteindre bah là c'est c'était ça donc
12 jours le partenariat le plus étrange
que tu as refusé
il y en a pas mal je pense que chaque
influenceur pourrait écrire un bouquin
sur les demandes chelou j'ai eu beaucoup
de
choses concernant la politique ce avec
quoi j'étais pas du tout à l'aise et je
trouve que ça c'est chelou parce que
parce qu'on sait comment ça fonctionne
et c'est un peu de ramener les gens je
trouve que c'est très très malsain
surtout les jeunes quand on sait qu'ils
ont pas encore eu le temps vraiment de
se créer une conscience politique de
même et avant même qui creuse de leur
côté de leur ramener des des
informations politiques je trouve que
c'est assez malsain donc je le rentrerai
dans la catégorie chelou et puis après
évidemment on a tous les types de
produits dropshipping produits qui
n'arriveront jamais arnaque produit
dangereux tabac alcool et le tutti
quantique des politiques qui t'ont
approché ça me rend curieux c'est quelle
partie tous
donc du coup ils ont essayé pourquoi
pour que tu ouais c'est mais c'est juste
pour se rendre aussi peut-être un peu
plus cool et jeunes ce que je comprends
ce qui est une bonne idée quand tu te
mets de leur côté en réunion je trouve
que c'est une bonne idée mais quand nous
on est de notre côté en fait à partir du
moment où tu te rends compte que c'est
des vrais personnes qui te suivent et
que c'est pas juste des chiffres c'est
des gens humains avec une conscience
avec leur façon de penser etc et je
trouve que c'est assez dangereux de de
les ramener vers des partis politiques
surtout quand c'est pas assez auquel toi
tu que tu soutiens quoi donc il y a une
différence entre partager ces valeurs et
rameuter politiquement et un petit peu
manipuler Antoine jamais allé faire ça
non je pense pas je te dis ça
aujourd'hui peut-être que
peut-être que j'aurais envie de devenir
mère de Paris un jour donc
mes potes mais c'est que j'aime
tellement Paris on dirait vraiment que
que je suis payée par la Ville de Paris
pour en faire la promotion mais je suis
vraiment la emilyn Paris sur votre vive
les vies la ville quoi il y a pas
longtemps tu as sorti une vidéo
justement avec sur emilyn Paris c'est ce
que un jour on peut devoir dedans
c'est pas prévu après moi j'adore les
exercices un peu nouveau et
la série me fait
me fait sourire je trouve ça je trouve
ça attendre récente de voir comment ils
imaginent les Français Paris et ils
mettent en lumière la ville de toute
façon ça reste et puis franchement merde
c'est quand même un peu drôle
donc pourquoi pas pourquoi pas mais il y
a pas de concret pour l'instant non non
ton artiste favori
rihanna dans
l'entièreté de sa carrière une source
d'inspiration au quotidien
c'est pas la meilleure qualité mais les
premiers vlogs doutes que je trouve
hyper mignon c'est que il y avait 300
personnes qui les regardaient et je
continuais de les poster et je suis
assez fière de ça de pas avoir attendu
que des gens regardent mes vidéos pour
faire des vidéos et justement c'est
juste qu'à quand tu comptes faire des
vlogs doutes
je pense que si un jour je dis j'arrête
les vlogs doutes les gens vont venir
chez moi et m'arracher ma perruque donc
non je sais pas je les ferai jusqu'à ce
que je trouve que ça fasse sens et après
c'est comme une bonne série tu vois
friends ils auraient pu continuer encore
des années moi j'aurais été là pour
garder mais des fois il y a des choses
qui sont vraiment très cool et qui
appartiennent à un temps et après ça
fait sens de fermer le chapitre mais ça
pourrait être cette année ça pourrait
être dans cinq ans je sais pas j'ai pas
de planning en tout cas s'il y a une
vidéo que tu regarderais aujourd'hui en
2023 sur ta chaîne où tu dirais ou là ça
j'aurais pas dû la poster ou tu dis bon
celle-là me gêne un petit peu
les premières vont me gêner de
trucs idiot quoi parce que j'étais très
très
timide beaucoup moins à l'aise face à la
caméra et puis je sens en fait je les
regarde et je me rappelle imaginer ce
que mes copains est-ce que les gens à
l'école allaient dire du coup j'étais
très très
timide et je m'étais même peu dans une
petite boîte dans cette toute première
vidéo mais je les ai laissés sur la
chaîne Youtube parce qu'elles font
partie d'une évolution elles font partie
d'un truc quoi donc ce serait
regrettable de les regretter un rêve
pour 2023
être en bonne santé physique et santé
mentale on en parlera pas mal dans
l'interview où tu te vois dans 10 ans
j'espère dans une grande maison avec une
chambre pour Marcus Solène mes parents
et un chien c'est dans 10 ans j'ai pas
un chien c'est que j'ai raté un truc il
y a le déménagement en cours j'ai vu là
je me suis fait
gentiment dégagé mon appartement les
propriétaires veulent le récupérer et du
coup ils m'ont dit ouais il faut que tu
le quittes j'étais pas prête à déménager
mais ça y est du coup là début 2023
c'est les cartons ah ouais là j'en
prends un carton là je vous quitte après
je vais aller faire des cartons bon
courage mon abrontant encore un petit
peu si tu devais décrire Léna situation
en trois mots ce serait lesquels
créatrice de contenu
facile
il y a un terme que j'ai vu souvent à la
fois dans ton podcast et encore même
hier dans ta Story c'est le terme de
l'anxiété
c'est un peu ton mood du moment ah c'est
mon mood de ma vie depuis
c'est
un sujet qui est assez difficile de
mettre des mots dessus étant donné que
dans ta tête c'est assez clair mais dès
qu'il faut passer le trajet de ce qui se
passe entre ta tête et le dire à voix
haute il y a toujours une sorte de
blocage et les mots se mélangent parce
que en réalité c'est un concept qui est
quand même assez flou et et d'autant
plus pour les personnes anxieuses
je pense entre nous on se comprend ou
des fois tu arrives pas à exprimer ce
qui se passe dans ton cerveau et tu
arrives pas à comprendre pourquoi en
fait pourquoi ton cerveau est mal
branché pourquoi tout le monde arrive à
avancer et toi d'un coup tu dois te
mettre sur pause pour repenser à toute
ta vie de ces 15 dernières années alors
que tout allait plutôt bien c'est quoi
c'est la crainte de pas être à la
hauteur c'est quoi c'est un
plus profond que ça c'est pas forcément
lié au travail c'est pas forcément lié à
ma situation c'est pas forcément lié à
quoi que ce soit c'est des choses qui
m'est arrivé déjà un peu avec l'école en
fait je m'en rends compte après ça fait
un grand boom quand évidemment ta vie
est exposée mais à la fin de la journée
c'est mon choix si j'ai envie d'arrêter
d'exposer ma vie je peux très bien le
faire je me ferais chier quand même mais
tu sais c'est des choses que tu
contrôles je contrôle mon contenu je
contrôle ce que je passe sur les réseaux
mais parfois je contrôle pas forcément
comment ma tête va assimiler toutes les
informations mais ce que tu contrôles la
petite voix dans ta tête est-ce que tu
nous en parle souvent justement est-ce
que c'est quelque chose d'incontrôlé
mais attendez vous savez que tout le
monde n'a pas la petite voix dans sa
tête
j'en parlais avec une amie et je disais
mais tu vois moi c'est la voix elle me
l'a dit il fallait que qu'on y aille
quoi
et en fait cette petite folle vous aussi
vous avez une petite voix dans votre
tête qui un peu trop même ah ouais moi
elle est super présente et c'est ma cops
quoi c'est une copine moi alors des fois
elle est pas très cool mais cette petite
voix dans ma tête je sais pas elle est
là au quotidien et on guide un peu nos
journées comme ça et
la petite voix dans ma tête peut être ma
plus grande
cheerleader mais elle peut être aussi ma
plus grande haters
je me rends compte que j'ai
intellectualise beaucoup de d'événements
qui sont assez
banal et qui ont pas besoin d'être
autant intellectualisé qui ont pas
besoin d'être autant remis en question
réfléchie et au final c'est ça peut-être
parfois qui qui pose souci
récemment le fait que tu rêvais d'être
une meilleure moi en disant que en fait
on ne voit que 10% de ce que tu pourrais
être donc il y a 90% qu'on connaît pas
encore mais du coup c'est quoi alors non
je vois que 10 % de ce que je pourrais
être mais ça ça vient surtout en début
d'année je pense que
ce truc un peu sociétal et collectif
qu'on a autour des bonnes résolutions
autour de de être une nouvelle personne
nouvelle année nouvelle moi et en fait
on est déjà très bien comme on est je
pense qu'on n'a pas besoin de toujours
de devoir aller chercher plus plus plus
plus et moi je j'ai pris un peu de temps
aussi pour m'en rendre compte que ce qui
est déjà là c'est à savourer ça
féliciter on en est déjà arrivé jusque
là bravo à nous hi-five pas besoin
d'être constamment dans cette recherche
de
tout recommencer à zéro à chaque année
je pense que aujourd'hui alors moi j'ai
25 ans vous je sais pas quel âge vous
avez mais tu vois tu calcules le nombre
de leçons que tu as pris en 25 ans tu
calcules le nombre de choses que tu as
pu vivre bah ça c'est des leçons qui
valent quelque chose et qui n'ont pas
besoin d'être toute balayé pour
recommencer à zéro parce qu'on est le
1er janvier c'est des leçons de vie
quelque part c'est complètement la leçon
de vie c'est du collectionnes les leçons
de vie les moments de vie les choses que
tu as appris et puis après tu essayes de
voir de te dire ok bah c'est cette
dernière année qu'est-ce qui m'a
réellement rendu heureux ou heureuse
comment je peux faire pour améliorer mon
quotidien et faire en sorte
de vivre le plus possible de ces moments
heureux il y a les leçons de vie mais il
y a aussi les moments plus compliqués tu
disais tout à l'heure il y a eu des
hauts débats
il y a ce que tu as vécu aussi en août
2022 quand tu fais une vidéo qui dénonce
le harcèlement que tu subis et que tes
proches subissent
tes parents ta grand-mère en Algérie ça
a été quoi la goutte d'eau qui t'a
poussé à poster notamment cette vidéo
voilà ce truc qui se dit bon bah voilà
là c'est trop ce qu'on imagine qu'il y
avait sûrement une succession
d'événements à quel moment tu dis bon là
il faut vraiment que que j'en parle que
je le partage est-ce que tu peux un peu
nous raconter tout ça
oui alors
en fait j'en ai déjà pas mal parlé de
tous ces harcèlement et des fois ça me
en fait des fois je me dis tu comprends
vous pouvez donc en parlent pas parce
qu'après tu es un peu catégorisé comme
la meuf qui sait faire soleil et non
mais je vous jure j'ai fait d'autres
choses que de me faire harceler mais
donc c'est vrai que c'est un sujet qui
reste quand même hyper important et sur
lequel je suis assez heureuse en avoir
parlé d'avoir mis la lumière sur ça
parce que je sais pas à quoi
ressemblerait aujourd'hui le contenu si
je continue de mentir et de faire
semblant que ça m'a pas du tout affecté
de faire semblant que que tout est OK et
que c'est normal d'aller chez des gens
pour les insulter d'aller retrouver des
membres de leur famille en Algérie pour
pouvoir leur dire que leur petite fille
est une
insérer tous les gros mots que vous
voulez et en fait je me sentais obligé
de le faire parce que justement on
arrivait à la période des vlogs doutes
on est au fin juillet et je me dis mais
je peux pas commencer demain à
faire une vidéo par jour une vidéo par
jour tu peux pas mentir tu peux pas tu
peux pas mettre un je suis pas une bonne
actrice tu vois donc tu peux pas mettre
un rôle pendant 31 jours dans une
situation où tu filmes toute la journée
tu montes tu bloques tu finis tu montes
et en fait tu peux pas mentir sur ça et
je pense que si j'avais pas mis le haut
là sur tout ça et je pense que si
j'avais pas dit ce que je ressentais
depuis ces 7 derniers mois j'aurais pas
réussi à faire les vlogs donc c'était
soit on fait les vlogs et on reprend les
bonnes bases et je vous dis un peu
d'aller vous faire [ __ ] aussi à tous
ceux qui m'ont fortement miné et qui
aussi vraiment c'est pas comme moi c'est
vraiment toutes les nanas sur Internet
et les mecs aussi en fait c'est c'est ce
qui est ce qui est triste c'est que
quand je poste cette vidéo donc j'ai un
énorme soutien qui est qui est fou mais
ce qui m'a pénible c'est le nombre de
créatrices de contenu qui m'ont mais
merci de mettre des mots sur ça parce
que c'est des choses que je ressens et
que je vis et en fait on sait pas
comment en parler on sait pas comment
aborder le sujet c'est un sujet qui est
tellement chelou et qui est trop bizarre
quand je le raconte à des gens j'ai pas
compris pourquoi des gens ont jeté des
œufs sur la porte de ta mère ah parce
que tu as fait un restaurant vegan j'ai
pas compris du coup je sais moi non plus
et comme ça vraiment de rationalité
mettre des mots sur quelque chose qui
est tellement peu rationnel c'est assez
compliqué ça te montait dans le coeur
dans l'esprit j'imagine au quotidien il
y avait cette envie de de le partager
peut-être aussi pour que ça change pour
que les gens de la salle défense je
pense que j'étais arrivé au moment où si
je le fais pas je crois pas que ce soit
pour ceux qui m'ont harcelé que j'ai
fait cette vidéo au contraire c'était
pour remercier enfin remercier ceux qui
étaient là et je l'ai fait aussi pour
pour
mais bon
récemment il y a pas mal de streameuse
qui ont pris la parole notamment sur
twitch pour évoquer pour dénoncer le
harcèlement les commentaires sexistes
qu'elles subissent
quel rôle toi tu peux aussi jouer pour
pour lutter contre ça on a vu notamment
il y a certaines initiatives qui étaient
mises en place sur twitch pour modérer
les commentaires
voilà comment faire pour que ça change
et avec la parole la voix que tu peux tu
peux porter aujourd'hui je pense que les
gens devraient tout simplement arrêter
d'être des connards je sais il y a pas
de de
solutions pour dire à une personne
d'Internet d'arrêter d'écrire des
messages désobligeants parce qu'une
femme est passée sur un écran tu vois il
y a en fait cette phrase est quand même
folle de se dire des nanas sur twitch se
font harceler parce que ce sont des
nanas on va pas leur parler de leur jeu
en allant parler de leur live on va pas
leur parler de de leur éloquence de
leurs idées de leurs valeurs on va leur
parler de leur physique on va leur
parler de du choix de leur tenue et
non c'est comment tu veux mettre une
règle sur un truc qui est aussi con
juste arrêtez d'être chiant et pardon
pour les gros mots mais arrêtez d'être
des obligeant
c'est une question d'éducation aussi
quelque part je pense que c'est une
question d'éducation pas forcément parce
que tu peux avoir reçu une très très
bonne éducation mais l'anonymat
d'internet peut te faire oublier le
temps d'un instant tout ce que le
système tes parents tes proches ont pu
je pense que l'anonymat d'internet
crée des choses très très positives
permet d'ouvrir la la conversation sur
énormément de sujets qui ne sont pas
abordés dans d'autres médias plus
traditionnels et justement sous couvert
d'anonymat tu peux te livrer plus tu
peux raconter des choses que tu
n'arriverais pas à faire avec ton nom
ton prénom ta tête affiché mais il y a
aussi cette partie beaucoup plus
négative où tu peux aussi te permettre
d'avoir des commentaires misogynes
racistes homophobes et toutes les autres
merde qui sont suivies ouais c'est un
débat même politique depuis des années
c'est la levée de l'anonymat sur
Internet
je sais pas si c'est vraiment
lever l'anonymat c'est vraiment que ça
permet aussi à des gens de s'exprimer de
pouvoir dire
il y a une responsabilité de la part des
plateformes il y a une responsabilité de
la part des créateurs de contenu nous on
peut pas juste prendre tous les aspects
positifs sans se dire oui à un moment tu
vas quand même avoir des aspects
négatifs sinon tu vis dans un monde de
bisounours et ce n'est pas réel mais je
pense que les plateformes ont du moins
j'ai l'impression essaye un petit peu de
faire avancer les choses en filtrant des
mots en mettant des contrôles parentaux
en étant en fait je pense surtout aux
plus jeunes tu vois moi j'ai 25 ans
aujourd'hui
un mec qui m'envoie sa teub
on sait pas la première que je reçois
ce qui arrive à dire en plus mais tu
imagines que c'est une petite fille ou
un petit garçon qui va recevoir ça qui a
13 ans qui qui commence à peine ou quoi
que ce soit je trouve que c'est ça c'est
moi donc c'est la responsabilité des
plateformes
respecter cette
responsabilité des plateformes quand on
voit par exemple sur twitch que c'est
des streamers qui sont obligés de
prendre eux-mêmes l'idée de créer une
liste pour censurer des mots pour faire
en sorte de protéger la communauté mais
je pense que on reste encore sur des
métiers on dit nouveau métier alors que
ça fait genre 15 ans que ça là mais je
pense que l'évolution était très très
grosse et je pense que tout le monde est
arrivé dans ce milieu en étant un peu
très optimiste et c'était à la base
c'est les réseaux c'est vraiment ça quoi
c'était l'activité extrascolaire de tout
le monde et c'était que que fun positif
et arc-en-ciel et maintenant je pense
que c'est ouais beaucoup plus sombre
donc il y a la responsabilité des
plateformes les responsabilité des
créateurs de contenu parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a un tel accès à nos
stats on a un tel
je sais qu'ils sont les gens qui me
suivent je vois la tranche d'âge donc
moi aujourd'hui c'est majoritairement
des personnes de mon âge mais je vois
qu'il y a encore une dose de 13-17 ans
même si elle est minime dans les stats
tu dis là il y a des enfants de 13-17
ans c'est pour ça que j'essaie de trop
dire de gros mots j'ai encore du mal
mais tu dis en fait je peux pas
qu'est-ce que c'est jeune là tu as envie
de leur raconter sans rentrer dans le
génie mais de faire un faux contenu en
mode Gulli pour garder ces jeunes là
mais comment tu peux les accompagner et
comment tu peux leur proposer les les
valeurs qui te touchent et toi tu
arrives vraiment à te protéger par
rapport à ça parce que j'imagine tu dis
justement où tu dois sûrement regarder
les commentaires les messages privés
je regarde souvent je vois que c'est
rempli de bon truc mais des fois c'est
plus compliqué tu sais quoi j'ai
l'impression que
je ça y est j'ai passé le cap et j'ai
fait la paix avec le fait que tu puisses
pas plaire à tout le monde j'ai fait la
paix avec le fait que ton contenu plat
va pas à tout le monde et puis j'ai fait
la paix aussi que je pense que beaucoup
de personnes vont projeter leurs
insécurités sur toi vont projeter des
choses négatives qui peuvent leur
arriver de leur côté ils vont te le
projeter sur toi et
quand je dis toi je parle pas que de moi
je parle sur internet en général
je pense que
vous proposer au mieux
mais c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus
incroyable
d'aimer soi-même ce que tu proposes et
de chercher son approbation à soi plutôt
que celle des autres mais je vois bien
l'idée parce que quand je regarde il
faut les mentions on peut avoir 99,9%
bons commentaires on a vu le 0,1 et ça
ça travaille c'est un peu ça c'est comme
moi je reçois mon bulletin scolaire il y
avait une prof ça m'avait elle avait pas
aimé mon trimestre ça me foutait la
haine pourquoi et bam bizarre mais c'est
bien c'est pas grave c'était nul en
sport on le sait déjà quoi
petite question pour ça sur un autre
sujet c'est comment on protège sa vie
privée
même voilà quand on se déplace dans la
rue alors je sais pas si je devrais le
dire mais je t'ai déjà croisé plusieurs
fois en Vélib' dans Paris c'est possible
c'est fort probable mais du coup comment
on se protège par rapport à ça parce que
c'est vrai que tu as une popularité qui
monte d'année en année et comment on
arrive à se dire bon bah surtout que les
réseaux sociaux poussent vraiment à
dévoiler beaucoup de choses avec une
limite quoi écoute je pense que c'est au
fil des années tu te rends compte qu'il
y a des choses avec lesquelles tu es à
l'aise d'autres moins je pense que c'est
propre à chaque créateur de contenu à sa
limite
moi je j'ai trouvé un certain confort en
racontant ma vérité et en racontant des
petites banalités du quotidien ça me
dérange pas qu'on
connaît pas mal d'aspects de ma vie
privée mais j'ai quand même une petite
ligne en protégeant les proches moi ça
me dérange pas tu vois mais c'est mon
choix tu veux pas l'imposer à tes à tes
proches que non absolument ils sont pas
dans ce corps de métier qui même pas
dans ce game là tu vois et qui prennent
pas forcément de plaisir donc du coup ça
va plus être protégé des proches
protéger ceux qui ne souhaitent pas être
exposés parce que aujourd'hui si tu te
fais un peu si on te voit dans des
vidéos des stories peut-être qu'on va te
reconnaître dans la rue même si je suis
plus avec toi et qu'on n'est pas en
train de tourner un vlog et tu peux
c'est un exercice quand même assez
particulier d'être dans son dans sa
petite balade et que quelqu'un t'arrête
pour faire une photo quoi que ce soit
par exemple je sais que moi mon petit
frère il est moins à l'aise avec ça il
me dit j'aime bien mais je sais pas
faire et je sens que je crée une sorte
de gêne quand on me demande une photo il
est en mode il sait pas quoi faire de
ses bras comment faire pour la photo et
tout mais ça lui plaît pas de ouf donc
du coup il y a des choses qu'on protège
mais c'est en fait je pense qu'il faut
pas se mettre la pression de vouloir en
montrer plus si t'es pas l'aise avec ce
que tu montres tu vois moi je suis plein
de créateurs de contenu ou je m'en fous
de savoir comment se décorer chez eux on
tape j'aime le contenu qui me propose et
j'ai pas envie d'en savoir plus je pense
que ma communauté a compris les choses
que je m'étais pas pas forcément en
avant et le respect est
on est bien avec ce que je monte déjà tu
vois quand tu gères ça par exemple quand
je sais pas si on crie tout le monde
dans la rue tu vois des gens qui vont te
suivre sur des dizaines de mètres voire
plus j'imagine que ça va arriver parfois
comment on gère ça un peu quand on est
des moments de vie privée quoi
franchement je gère plutôt bien parce
que j'ai la chance vraiment
André que je fais la salut ça va
c'est la vie faut vivre non mais c'est
quand même fou on est dans les bureaux
de bruit un lundi matin il y a du monde
les embêter là ils vont tous dans nos
prud'hommes à cause de cette interview
on a voulu que tu viennes un lundi parce
qu'il y a du monde si on avait fait le
vendredi ça aurait vraiment fait
l'arnaque total et on aurait fait il y a
pas grand monde donc c'est pour ça on a
voulu que voilà il y a du monde qui
travaille sur les bureaux et tout parce
que sinon voilà c'est compliqué du coup
je disais le
sur la ma communauté vraiment très très
cool très bienveillante et en même temps
ça te fait du bien aussi qu'on d'avoir
une sorte d'interaction humaine avec des
gens avec lesquels tu une Converse que
en ligne tu sais c'est oh mon travail
major de ce que je fais moi c'est comme
là je suis sur l'ordinateur et je fais
du montage ou alors je fais des mails et
donc ma journée c'est vraiment constitué
de être seul derrière l'ordinateur donc
quand tu rencontres des gens dans la
vraie vie en 3D que tu vois comment il
parle comment il s'habillent comment ils
interagissent je trouve que c'est hyper
hyper enrichissant et alors parfois il y
a des jours où je suis plus pressé que
d'autres de toute façon quand tu m'as vu
je trace
en trottinette électrique à ce moment là
je suis passé aussi mais on a est-ce que
je t'ai tracé
le casque ou alors juste des fois un
petit sourire un petit comme ça et
parfois on a plus peur pour ma sécurité
parce que moi je suis une petite fille
tu vois ça m'arrive des fois qu'on
peut faire des mouvements de fou les
trucs comme ça ouais moi tu peux me tuer
facilement j'ai vu un mètre 60
et comment on arrive à garder des
moments pour soi
avec moi-même
j'arrive à prendre des rendez-vous avec
moi-même je me suis instaurée des
règles que je me force à tenir
tous les matins je me fais une petite
balade avant de venir vous voir je suis
j'ai marché pendant trois quarts d'heure
en fait je fais ça tous les matins c'est
c'est au début je détestais le faire
j'en ai pourquoi je me réveille pour
aller marcher enfin tu sais une
demi-heure de sommeil c'est
un cadeau quoi quand le matin tu te
gratte une demi-heure c'est génial avant
de dormir
de sommeil elle est précieuse elle est
belle c'est un cadeau tu remercie le
ciel de que tu te réveilles qui reste
encore une demi-heure à dormir
et les premières fois je me suis dit bon
allez je vais aller marcher quoi
pourquoi je sais pas dans quel but je
sais pas mais en fait c'est parce qu'à
un moment j'étais très très très
miracle morning qui ne sorte de
Conseils de développement personnel de
commencer sa journée pas avec le rush de
la journée mais avec un mini en calme
que tu as accordé à toi et au début
genre je me réveille à 4h du matin pour
ma carotter du temps avec moi puis après
je me suis rendu compte que bon ça y est
on se connaît bien moi et moi dis on va
dormir quoi
même et ça m'a non par contre je rigole
mais ça m'a beaucoup aidé ça m'a rendu
juste ne pas commencer sa journée sur du
stress c'est ça change le rythme de
toute ta journée et ça peut paraître
très bête que cette demi-heure vraiment
régule mon humeur sur la journée donc
voilà je prends le temps avec moi-même
sinon après j'aime aussi
quand je sens que j'ai eu beaucoup
d'informations dans la semaine et je
sens que j'ai vu trop de gens ou quoi
que ce soit je dis à tout le monde de
façon bienveillante je sais
plaisir je vous adore tous mais là je
crois qu'il faut que je passe
l'après-midi toute seule moi-même parce
que sinon je vais j'ai pas encore eu le
temps de mâcher tout ce qui se passe
j'ai pas le temps de digérer je suis
encore en train de le mâcher donc si on
peut juste me laisser une aprèm seul et
tu vas te balader aussi nez le ciné seul
c'est un vrai truc hein c'est pas mal
parce qu'en fait quelque part au
quotidien tu es dans une
hypersocialisation ou tu croises des
centaines de personnes potentiellement
qui veulent te parler entre le pro les
gens qui te reconnaissent et il y a
aussi le moment où on se dit c'est super
on adore les gens mais il faut aussi se
retrouver avec soi-même exactement je
suis une introverti très sociable parce
que quoi de base c'était plutôt timide
plutôt tu n'arrivais pas trop à aller
vers les gens
j'étais timide avec mes propres idées je
pense que l'âge adolescence est
inévitable mais c'est un peu continuant
en grandissant j'étais timide avec mes
idées c'est à dire que j'avais des rêves
que je n'osais même pas moi
accepter parce que j'ai trouvé trop fou
et du coup c'est vrai que au début
j'étais timide avec moi-même et tu sais
quand tu as du mal à assumer quitter
l'assumer devant les autres encore plus
compliqué mais après une
en fait une fois l'adolescence passait
le je parle de l'adolescence comme si
j'avais 50 ans mais une fois le collège
passé je crois tu fais un peu à la paix
avec ton corps tu fais un peu la paix
avec tes complexe alors après il y en a
plus ou moins qui reste mais petit à
petit tu te rends compte que chacun est
dans son côté chacun est dans son dans
son monde et en réalité si tu fais un
truc de ouf
que toi tu as trouvé un truc de ouf les
gens ils vont pas s'en rendre compte
donc tu peux aller tu peux aller
gambader tu peux aller courir tu peux
aller avoir des grands rêves tu peux
aller seul au ciné personne n'a mal te
regardé tu peux aller manger seul au
restaurant les gens en fait sont
concentrés sur eux-mêmes tu vois
c'est vraiment des gros connards mais
ils sont on est tous concentrés dans
notre petit train de vie tu vois on est
déjà préoccupé par nos petites bulles et
tout voilà on est préoccupé par nos
angoisses et nos problèmes on
se concentre pas sur ceux des autres
ça ressemble à quoi une journée de Léna
situation là tu nous as pas été ta
petite balade mais après c'est une
journée type parce que j'imagine qu'il y
a des tu vas me dire aussi il y a
toujours et qui se ressemblent mais il y
a peut-être des fois des moments où
écoute la blague qu'on fait avec mes
potes c'est que tu prends deux activités
qui n'ont rien à voir ensemble tu les
mets les unes après les autres et c'est
une journée de
youtubeuse quoi c'est un autre sujet
aussi que je pouvais je trouvais
important c'est celui de la santé
mentale justement comment on prend soin
de sa propre santé mentale quand on est
justement au quotidien observer
critiquer commenter tous les jours je
pense que la vraie question c'est
comment prendre soin de sa santé mentale
tout court parce que c'est chacun
individuellement on a
nos angoisses nos problèmes les petits
petits dos d'âne dans ta journée et
c'est pas propre aux créateur de contenu
au contraire nous on est dans des
situations qui sont très privilégiés je
te rappelle je travaille j'ai tronçonné
ma passion en un travail c'est pas des
journées de travail c'est des journées
de kiffe alors évidemment il y a des
moments qui sont plus
traditionnels et relou que d'autres
quand je me retrouve enfin les vrais
les vraies tâches d'une chaîne
d'entreprise mais c'est un privilège
immense donc moi ma santé mentale elle
se des problèmes
de qualité j'ai envie de te dire
trop de gens regardent mes vidéos d'un
côté j'ai tout fait pour que les gens
regardent mes vidéos et je continue de
le faire pour que les gens prennent du
plaisir à regarder mon contenu donc je
peux pas me plaindre maintenant d'avoir
des yeux sculptés sur moi alors que j'ai
tout fait pour donc ça c'est
mes leçons à moi j'en parlerai à ma
thérapeute mais
par contre la santé mentale d'un point
de vue général moi c'est laquelle je
pense qu'il faut mettre vraiment de la
lumière c'est toute cette génération qui
vient de finir les cours en covid il y
en a qui ont passé leur bac à distance
il y en a qui qui ont fait les deux ans
de à la maison en télétravail de l'école
télétravail à la fin de la journée tu as
gagné l'argent tu vois télétravail de
l'école c'est
moi l'école j'ai tenu parce que il y a
les amis parce qu'il y a l'ambiance
parce qu'il y a les moments
magiques et magnétique avec les copains
que tu te fais au lycée et au collège
donc pour moi c'est les gens qui font
vraiment
applaudir déjà c'est toutes ces toutes
la génération après nous qui viennent de
se taper ça cette génération qui est
moins mise en lumière qu'une
influenceuse qui fait juste des vidéos
sur YouTube et la santé mentale ce que
j'adore c'est que enfin ce que j'adore
je n'adore pas simplement mal tourné la
santé mentale je trouve que ce qui est
vraiment très positif en ce moment c'est
que
le tabou s'enlève petit à petit déjà le
mot devient un mot du quotidien genre
c'est devenu stylé de dire santé mentale
genre c'est devenu un sujet
d'actualité alors que c'est présent
depuis absolument toujours je pense que
vraiment si le jour du Moyen-Âge ou pas
de leur santé mentale il faudrait
vraiment des thérapeutes de ouf parce
que ce qu'ils ont mangé aussi chaud ça
va être compliqué mais le sujet s'ouvre
le tabou s'enlève et je pense que plus
on va en parler plus on va vraiment
déculpabiliser les gens de ressentir des
choses plus les gens qui ont vraiment
besoin d'être écoutés ou juste même de
parler même si les personnes ne les
écoute et que eux s'écoutent même c'est
gagné c'est vrai il y avait un côté
tabou ça pouvait mettre vu comme une
faiblesse quelque part
je suis partie voir le spectacle de
roman Frayssinet son dernier one-man Joy
qui est génial je vous le recommande et
dans son one man show il fait une vanne
bah toujours très pertinente un roman il
fait une vanne sur dire que pleurer
c'est
c'est la honte et qu'un homme qui pleure
c'est c'est la honte et qu'on part en
fait pleurer c'est des émotions que
d'extériorise comme chier littéralement
et que tu vas pas dire à quelqu'un à la
honte
tu chies quoi et donc lui il comparé moi
c'est très c'est du roman tu vois mais
qu'on parle les larmes
à cette sortie d'émotion cette sortie de
d'expression ça a besoin de sortir tu
vois et donc du coup il encourageait
toute la salle à pleurer et accepter de
pleurer que même un homme qui pleure
c'est pas la honte contrairement à ce
que beaucoup de gens peuvent vous faire
penser et il y a un besoin pour toi
justement d'extérioriser tout ça de
partager ça avec ta communauté c'est
vrai que aujourd'hui voilà quand tu as
un moment bah voilà on parlait de
l'anxiété que tu peux vivre on se début
d'année c'est important d'en parler de
le partager avec les gens que tu aimes
et en même temps les gens qui te suivent
aussi
tu sais quoi je pense que c'est
important d'en parler parce que moi ça
m'a fait du bien de me connecter sur
Youtube et de voir qu'il y avait des
cours de méditation guidées gratuits
libres d'accès que il y avait des
nanas qui et des mecs qui parlaient de
leur anxiété donc du coup j'arrive à
mettre des mots sur ce que je ressentais
mais alors que j'étais encore en train
d'intérioriser beaucoup de choses et en
fait ce côté un peu de t'es pas tout
seul quand tu fais l'anxiété quand ta
tête vraiment t'isole du monde autour de
toi c'est c'est une grande aide et
comme un câlin moi je le vis comme ça ça
te fait du bien justement de ça me fait
du bien d'entendre des gens en parler et
ça me fait du bien d'en parler et de
voir que tu es pas le seul à vivre ça
et puis je vois aussi ce que tu disais
tout à l'heure c'est de relativiser
parce que tu dis bon voilà ce que je vis
dans mon quotidien mais qui peut-être un
quotidien privilégié et en même temps tu
parlais des étudiants avec ce qu'ils ont
vécu pendant le covid on a vu aussi les
distributions alimentaires où il y a eu
beaucoup plus de monde qu'auparavant
c'est toujours d'essayer de relativiser
par rapport à des situations plus
compliquées évidemment mais c'est étudie
peut-être un quotidien privilégié non
c'est c'est clairement ça pour moi à
partir du moment où tu travailles avec
ta passion c'est on peut plus se
plaindre tu peux avoir des moments down
mais
relativise
c'est pareil c'est aussi métier passion
en mode bon bah voilà on va sur le
terrain des fois c'est dur des fois
c'est compliqué mais on compte pas 16
heures quoi non parce que c'est ce qui
t'anime c'est ce qui t'habite et c'est
ta lumière en toi et vraiment je
souhaite à toutes les personnes qui qui
nous écoutent si vous avez cette lumière
en vous vraiment mais je vous le
souhaitez vous méritez de pouvoir nous
faire que ça de vos journées alors moi
perso je suis pas très fan du montage
c'est un peu la partie où j'ai un petit
peu plus de mal c'est chronophage je
préfère sur le terrain de tourner toi de
ton côté c'est quoi le le montage ça va
les tournages c'est quoi le truc un
petit peu plus compliqué la petite tache
où tu dis bon bah ça j'ai un peu de mal
la partie que j'aime le moins c'est
faire les miniatures oh c'est la petite
vignette que tu vois quand tu cliques
sur Youtube et je suis mauvaise je suis
mauvaise je
l'ai même à faire sur Tik Tok ici à brut
et des fois je me dis je sais pas
pourquoi je fais ça
pour faire une miniature
j'ai l'impression que je sais plus
utiliser l'interface quoi et encore le
temps de faire tes montages soi-même
mais après je suis moins régulière que
ce que je faisais avant parce que
justement je
préfère aujourd'hui avoir plus de
qualité que de quantité
alors que les réseaux nous poussent
vraiment à poster le plus possible les
et en fait je me suis rendu compte que
moi j'avais trouvé mon
ma joie en étant fier de ce que je poste
donc même si c'est même si
j'aurais pu faire trois montages pas ouf
je préfère en faire un dans je suis
fière et devenir ok bon c'était la bonne
vidéo possible
il y a quelque chose que j'ai remarqué
tu me dis si je me trompe mais on voit
que tu utilises de plus en plus ton nom
de famille
dans tes publications
[Musique]
j'avoue que j'ai pas fait une enquête
approfondie de compter combien une
citation 2020
c'est magique ouais c'est l'heure de
manger je pense
en fait tout le monde bosse à six jument
et dès qu'il y en a un qui se lève c'est
parti
mais qui est le plus brave pour se lever
en premier et dernier on va manger
ça peut être moi parce que je prends
jamais de petit déjeuner donc voilà du
coup je suis un peu en retard
je comprends la question parce que en
effet c'est un nom de famille rebeu et
j'en suis fier enfin c'est même pas une
question quoi c'est celui que j'ai
depuis toujours et même si ma value
quelques mots cris au collège et au
lycée puisque ma pouf voilà je vous
laisse faire le schéma et imaginer tous
les sons que j'ai pu avoir à l'école
mais non ça m'a pas
j'en suis fière les questions à une
époque tu disais avant avec une
réservation de mafouf il n'y avait pas
de place avec les nations il y en a
quelque part c'est que sur certains
restaurants les restaurants prétentieux
parisiens
ça c'est les pierres et justement
comment tu vis aujourd'hui peut-être
certaines remarques que tu as pu subir
et des gens qui ont aussi peut-être des
noms justement arabe à consonance arabe
le racisme que peuvent subir de jeunes
filles hommes qui sont aussi les enfants
d'immigrés de première ou deuxième
génération parce que c'est vrai que
ce que tu as peut-être pu vivre dans
certains restaurants certains le vivent
pour un entretien d'embauche pour pour
un appartement c'est ce qui est assez
fou c'est que toutes ces questions qu'on
me pose aujourd'hui
quand on les épaule ah oui en effet ça
fait sens mais en fait c'est un racisme
qui est tellement banalisé qui est de
l'ordre du quotidien que tu sais même
quand j'étais petite et qu'on se moquait
de mes cheveux bouclés et que
c'était amusant de se moquer de mes
cheveux bouclés je voyais pas plus loin
que juste les cheveux sont pas jolis je
voyais pas tout ce que ça pouvait
impliquer je voyais en fait je
comprenais pas non plus l'importance et
le message que passent des cheveux
bouclés assumés toutes les mains sont
très présentes sur les lâche
et je me rendais pas compte de tout le
message que c'est par exemple au
Festival de Cannes j'ai porté mes
cheveux bouclés naturels c'est la
première fois que je vous en tapis rouge
avec mes cheveux naturels 24 ans après
une bataille contre contre des complexes
et contre justement tous ces messages
qui me reviennent d'un coup dans la tête
quand je vais lâcher mes cheveux ceux
qui viennent de mes copines
mes camarades blanches à l'école et en
fait
je me rendais pas compte du message
politique on allait après me demander de
porter quand j'avais juste mis mes
cheveux bouclés naturels sur un tapis
rouge et en fait j'ai senti moi une
immense fierté de réussir à le faire et
d'avoir combattu tout ce tous ces
complexes qui ont été créés c'est pas
que par mes camarades mais c'est la
société en général c'est les dictats de
la beauté surtout chez les femmes on
nous mène une telle pression pour être
jolie fille une présente
volontaire
on est fatigué aussi et donc du coup se
retrouver à porter ça c'est une certaine
fierté mais le message politique juste
pour des cheveux bouclés
ça m'angoisse en fait à quel point il y
a tellement de représentations que s'il
suffit que une personne le fasse et
c'est un Bigdil ça devrait pas être un
Bigdil ça devrait pas être un message
politique de porter ses cheveux naturels
quand toutes les meufs portent leurs
cheveux lisses naturels sont des tapis
rouge tu vois pourquoi quand c'est nana
aux cheveux bouclés qui va le faire ça
va être
un message politique non c'est mes
cheveux je suis née avec j'ai longtemps
essayé de les camoufler j'ai longtemps
essayé de ressembler
au vôtre maintenant que je les porte
fièrement
je comprends pas le concept
du message aussi politique et d'un côté
surtout qu'il est très important ça me
fait penser à une question sur le le
rapport au corps tu parlais souvent des
13-17 ans tout à l'heure tu as beaucoup
de jeunes filles qui qui te suivent qui
peuvent s'identifier à toi comme
d'autres personnalités et voilà souvent
on va voir des photos qui peuvent être
retouchées où on présente le corps
féminin de façon idéalisée ça peut créer
des complexes chez certaines qui vont
essayer d'identifier à ces corps-là
comment a ton échelle tu fais justement
pour pour éviter ça pour pour se dire
aussi voilà les 13 17 ans qui me suivent
où il y a un rapport qui est compliqué
avec le corps donc soyez à l'aise soyez
à l'aise dans ce que vous êtes dans ce
que vous faites tu vois ce qui est
rigolo c'est que quand tu me poses la
question tu mets au féminin tu dis les
filles qui te suivent pour les complexes
je pense que les justement on pense
directement aux femmes parce que c'est
majoritairement sur les femmes qu'on
injecte beaucoup de dictats de beauté je
pense que les garçons aussi ont leur
lots de complexe et c'est plus discret
chez vous mais mais si on parle des
cheveux qui tombent je peux t'assurer
que tous les garçons de la rédaction
vont faire quoi mes cheveux tombent vous
aussi vous avez votre lot de
ça rigole derrière la cave je regarde
tous les deux trois mois
j'ai bien tous les deux trois mois si
j'ai pas un début de calvitie perso
c'est vraiment propre à
quasi tout le monde et je pense que
cette question doit plus se poser sur
les médias plus traditionnelles ceux qui
ont longtemps décidé volontairement de
n'afficher que un certain type de femme
que un certain type de garçon quand les
médias et les enfin quand les réseaux
sociaux sont arrivés en ouvrant la
conversation justement sur ça je pense
aujourd'hui que j'avais pas eu les
réseaux sociaux on n'aurait pas
aujourd'hui
la représentation qui est en train de
changer on aurait pas sur les affiches
publicitaires dans le métro que ce soit
marqué photo retoucher parce que c'est
une nouvelle génération qui est une
sorte de ras-le-bol en disant en fait on
n'arrive plus à suivre tout ce que vous
nous demandez d'être on n'arrive plus à
suivre ce camouflage qu'on nous en train
de faire on a besoin que que ça change
parce qu'en fait là on arrive à un peu à
apprendre mon retour tu vois
pourtant c'est important justement te
présenter sur tes réseaux naturels quoi
aussi
ça peut être quand tu te réveilles le
matin alors des moments aussi très
apprêtés quand il est défilé mais aussi
des moments plus simple de la vie
quotidienne pour que l'on se disent bah
voilà la vie c'est aussi quand on se
réveille le matin je suis comme vous en
soit ah mais je suis pire que vous
surtout ah oui non c'est sûr moi je
prends un malin plaisir pendant une
fashion week chansons d'être en soirée
déguisé toute la semaine et tu mets des
extensions tu mets du make-up et tout
mais mon bonheur ne résulte pas sur ça
mon bonheur ne se résulte pas sur mon
apparence et pareil c'est ce qu'on
disait avec les cheveux bouclés au début
quand j'ai commencé à faire des vidéos
YouTube et que je me rendais pas
forcément compte du nombre de personnes
qui regardaient les vidéos je vais
toujours été très à l'aise peut-être
parfois un peu trop à l'aise de montrer
démaquiller décoiffer pyjamais
bien jogosser tu vois et et
des fois je faisais des interviews par
la suite dans des médias
magazines etc elle me dit vous êtes
tellement féministe de vous montrer
démaquiller étant
en fait ça prouve que tout ce qu'on a
consommé
est tellement retouchée édulcorer mise
en scène que d'avoir une petite nana qui
en plus d'être 18 ans qui se monte
démaquillés c'est un big move tu dis non
vraiment c'est de l'ordre de c'est la
base quoi c'est ça devrait pas être
encore une fois ça devrait pas être un
message politique d'avoir une nana
démaquée dans une vidéo YouTube je vous
en supplie
le combat ne se cache pas dans ça quoi
donc je comprends aujourd'hui que ça ça
se retrouve dans des questions
d'interview mais crois-moi que quand
j'ai commencé à montrer démaquiller il y
avait pas du tout de de choix politiques
non il y avait au contraire essayer
d'être à l'aise dans ses baskets essayer
aussi de trouver jolie son filtre
instinct voilà ça fait deux ans que j'ai
arrêté les filtres dans les stories
Instagram français le filtre facile qui
fait la police et qui te change
comme ça et en fait j'étais arrivé dans
une sorte de
dysmorphy ou en fait je me regardais
dans le miroir sans le filtre mais il
est où mon petit tache de rousseur elles
sont où et mon petit nez et
j'en arrive à un moment où il fallait
que je fasse une sorte de désintox parce
que chanter que si tu trouves jolie que
à travers le filtre insta je savais que
j'allais me
me perdre un petit peu alors je suis en
toute autre sujet toi par le passé tu as
évoqué entre guillemets la honte de tes
PARENTS tu leur en voulais de ne pas
gagner plus d'argent oui pourquoi
c'était quoi sentiment à l'époque parce
que j'étais dans une école privée à
l'époque attention je suis pas fière de
ce que je vais vous dire c'est assez
vulnérable pour moi de vous dire cette
cette phrase mais en effet quand je suis
rentrée dans une école privée donc mes
parents avaient mis leurs économies
un amour ultime que le mot qu'un parent
porte pour son enfant et ils ont fait
des sacrifices pour que je puisse faire
mes études et donc du coup je me
retrouve cette école privée avec des
camarades dont les parents n'avaient pas
dû faire les mêmes sacrifices que mes
parents et pour qui le prix de l'année
c'était pas une grosse dépense tu vois
et donc du coup forcément je me suis
retrouvé dans une sorte de de choc un
peu de classe sociale et
j'avais l'impression que comme mes
copines avaient des jolis sacs des jolis
bagues des jolis lieux de vacances et
d'aller au Club Med et tout je trouvais
ça ouf et bah il y a eu le premier mois
quand je suis arrivée dans cette école
où j'étais
j'étais en vieux en fait j'étais en mode
mais pourquoi
pourquoi moi mes parents ils ont décidé
de justement avoir des métiers passion
pourquoi mon père il a décidé d'être
intermittent du spectacle ok il a d'en
faire du spectacle mais bon il aurait pu
être PDG d'une grosse boîte quoi comme
ça j'aurais eu comme mes copines les
vacances au Club Med et
au final
tu te rends compte de la bêtise tes yeux
s'adoucissent aussi sur les vrais
valeurs de la vie et les vrais cadeaux
de la vie et moi mes cadeaux c'était que
justement mes parents en faisant ses
choix passion était présent quand je
rentrais de l'école ma maman elle était
là il m'aidait pour mes doigts j'avais
la
richesse de qui soit présent la richesse
de l'amour au quotidien la richesse de
l'amour la richesse des sacrifices
qu'ils ont fait pour que je puisse faire
mes études et même quand j'en parle
encore avec eux aujourd'hui je leur ai
dit tout ça pour que je finisse
youtubeuse quand même et ils disent non
aucun regret ce chemin était le tien et
et pour rien au monde échangerait
ce choix tu vois donc donc non je
et puis après en grande salle tu te
rends compte que vraiment vraiment le
bonheur ne se résulte pas dans le dans
le sac Chanel que ma copine avait eu
pour ses 18 ans parce qu'aujourd'hui tu
l'as et
en fait c'est que je me suis offert moi
et je me suis offert parce que
avec de l'argent que j'ai gagné en
faisant quelque chose que j'aimais faire
et ça c'est
une sorte de magie quoi de pouvoir être
fier de ce que tu fais au travail mais
surtout d'être
content tu sais c'est un vrai privilège
c'est
trouver du travail c'est horrible et
être au quotidien dans un job dans
lequel tu es pas là dans lequel tu n'es
pas
apprécier à ta juste valeur être dans un
métier où en fait tu es juste un
pion un peu remplaçable
c'est une vraie
une vraie à traverser et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui oui évidemment que moi je
suis contente d'avoir réussi à faire mon
petit truc mais
je sais pas très reconnaissante en tout
cas sur ton parcours justement tu as
déjà tu as déjà tu ne voulais pas servir
d'exemple à la théorie de la mérité le
canton veut on peut mais pourtant quand
on regarde ton parcours on voit que tu
t'es donné énormément de mal tu as fait
t'accumuler des petites jobs pour payer
tes études il y a eu ton année à New
York
est-ce que tu représentes un petit peu
malgré tout symbole
c'est quoi moi j'ai un côté très
schizophrène sur ça parce que j'ai ce
truc où
tu étais forcément au courant de ton
privilège déjà juste d'être né dans une
famille aimante c'est ouf moi quand j'ai
grandi d'essai je crois que c'était la
base pour tout le monde et au final
avoir des parents présents papa et maman
heureux et
qui donne de l'amour à leurs enfants ça
déjà ça te construit vraiment beaucoup
de choses dans ta tête quoi c'est que
j'arrivais avec des idées mais parents
ils les écoutaient ils m'ont jamais dit
tu devras faire ce parcours là et c'est
comme ça et pas autrement donc ça
privilège énorme donc évidemment tu pars
avec un temps d'avance je suis en France
tu en avance carte Vitale pas en avance
donc du coup évidemment qu'il y a ce
côté en avance mais c'est pas pour
autant que j'ai aussi ce truc de me dire
si moi j'ai réussi à sortir de
ce petit chemin qui devait être beaucoup
plus traditionnel et classique pour
créer ce que je voulais faire mais
maintenant que si moi j'ai réussi j'ai
pas utilisé de la magie j'ai pas utilisé
des contacts magiques j'ai pas utilisé
de l'argent magique pour mettre du ciel
non j'ai si j'avais juste vraiment très
très envie de le faire et évidemment je
me suis donné le moyen les moyens et il
y a un moment où je travaillais beaucoup
beaucoup dans l'objectif de vivre ce que
je suis en train de vivre aujourd'hui
mais j'ai encore ce truc de me dire si
moi j'ai réussi à le faire
je pense que
que c'est faisable parce que même moi je
misais pas sans moi à la base ta maman
alors que j'étais
là quoi j'étais juste j'étais le mettre
par là j'étais
je rêvais moins d'assister aux défis
c'est quelque chose vraiment qui m'a
toujours émerveillé le milieu de la mode
je te parle pas de faire du shopping je
te parle de l'art de la mode le vrai la
haute couture la création dans les
ateliers c'est quelque chose qui m'a
toujours fasciné animé et j'ai toujours
voulu être une petite souris dans les
ateliers pour pouvoir après par la suite
partager ça en avec des gens qui comme
moi ont rêvé et donc du coup mes
premières Fashion Week j'allais devant
les défilés avec un rêve tout simplement
et je suppliais les gens de d'avoir une
petite place pour rentrer et ça a marché
et c'est comme ça que j'ai fait mes
premiers défilés c'est comme ça que j'ai
rencontré mes les premières personnes
qui avaient un pied dans la mode et
petit à petit j'ai essayé de de montrer
qui j'étais ce que je voulais faire donc
évidemment vraiment que que tu pars d'un
privilège ce que je faisais avant mais
il y a quand même une certaine partie de
il fallait y croire vraiment très très
fort
et se donner les moyens j'en perds qui
traîne je comprends
non
tu as ce truc aussi de dire
en vrai je l'ai juste fait
il y a aussi la question tu parlais de
la fashion week-end qui sont assez
prestigieux comment on arrive à rester
authentique quand on est invité
justement à des défilés de mode qu'on
fait des partenaires avec des grandes
marques qu'on gagne aussi plus d'argent
comment on arrive à garder les pieds sur
terre bah si ton
si tes valeurs bases restent les mêmes
si tu vas un défiler juste pour montrer
que toi tu as été un défilé que c'est
juste une part d'ego évidemment que tu
vas y perdre beaucoup en authenticité
par contre si tu vas dans le but de de
partager ce que tu viens de vivre en te
disant ok bah moi j'ai eu la chance
et peut-être qu'ils se sont trompés mais
en tout cas ils m'ont invité j'ai eu la
chance de rentrer dans ce milieu très
fermé maintenant rentrez avec moi quoi
on dit un peu ce truc de à travers la
caméra même si j'arrive pas à faire
venir 3 millions de personnes sur un
défilé parce que
c'est du monde ça fait du monde mais par
contre si à travers un vlog à travers
des stories à travers des lives je peux
faire vivre une chose qu'un petit bout
de ce que je suis en train de vivre je
suis gardes tes bonnes bases ici la
question vis-à-vis de ton entourage
j'imagine voilà on passe
d'une étudiante quelqu'un de très connu
est-ce que tu as réussi à garder tes
amis d'enfance
il faut pas s'entourer de yES man on
appelle ça les Yes semaine 11 minutes il
y a beaucoup de gens de qui entourent
une personnalité un artiste ou quoi que
ce soit qui disent oui à tout oui c'est
super oui c'est génial oui il vient on
fait ça mais c'est parce que c'est des
gens qui qui vivent aux dépens de si toi
tu vis quoi donc c'est des gens qui
gagnent de l'argent statut gagner de
l'argent tu as entouré de Yes Man tu
vois et le but c'est de complètement se
séparer de ça et d'être entouré de gens
honnêtes et qui de plus honnête que ceux
qui connaissaient avant que
que des gens te suivent ça veut dire que
quand on est en 2023 qu'on s'appelle les
nations se faire de nouveaux amis soit
un peu compliqué non après ça va je sais
pas non plus un monstre j'ai bon
se protéger quelque part parce que c'est
vrai qu'il y a aussi la notion des gens
qui peuvent profiter qui peuvent
évidemment mais bon
en fait il faudrait que tu rencontres
Marcus et Solène mes deux meilleurs amis
pour te dire qu'il même si on voulait
faire rentrer quelqu'un d'autre
il y a plus de place déjà on se parle
les uns sur les autres on se voit toute
la journée tout le temps j'ai plus de
place du tout bah c'est ton vrai cercle
qui était là avant et ceux qui seront là
après c'est juste ça qui faut se dire et
c'est des gens en fait quand j'ai une
mauvaise idée non mais Léna c'est
vraiment de la merde et c'est ceux qui
vont te dire mais excuse-moi mais je
comprends pas dans ta vidéo tu as dit ça
mais ça veut pas dire articule tu vois
c'est ceux qui te qui te veulent du bien
et c'est surtout ceux qui t'en fous sans
enfin
j'imagine que ce que tu sais tu as plein
de gens qui vont dire oui à tout parce
qu'ils ont envie de te faire plaisir ils
osent pas forcément de contredire et
heureusement que tu as ces gens là qui
sont à la base et qui vont dire où tu
fais de la merde ils sont capables de
tous les parents donc la vérité sortira
toujours de leur bouche si un jour je me
laisse pousser des ailes
une question qui est aussi importante on
l'a vu cette année je sais pas comment
tu as suivi un peu ce clash perpétuel
entre Booba et Magali Berda mais ça a
posé la question justement de tout ce
qui est en lien avec les partenariats
comment toi tu fais pour ce que tu pour
que ces partenariats soient éthiques
pour ce que tu partages avec ta
communauté ça respecte justement les
valeurs que tu veux véhiculer au
quotidien il y a des règles il y a des
lois qui sont qui sont bien bien
inscrites et ses lois de demandes de ne
pas parler de produits dangereux
frauduleux de dropshipping alors ça
reste très floue que ça veut réellement
dire parce que on a encore sur un métier
qui est pas 100% structuré d'un point de
vue légal mais ça va vachement se
légiférer avec le temps donc grosso modo
tu ce que je fais c'est que je parle de
marque que je consomme je parle de
marque que j'apprécie je parle de marque
dont
bon je suis à l'aise de parler et
j'essaye aussi un petit peu de
diversifier et de pas parler que toi je
travaillais avec des maisons de mode et
de couture donc du coup évidemment c'est
pas la pâte les mêmes prix et j'essayais
un peu juste de trouver une bonne
balance j'essaie de trouver un peu avec
le quoi je suis le plus à l'aise mais en
réalité je me j'ai mes petites règles
mais
j'ai quelques
quelques clients à l'année et la
question c'est de se dire
peut-être des entreprises qui
respecteraient pas d'énormes écologiques
ou qui pensaient de base de
ce produit est-ce que tu le consomme ou
est-ce que tu es en train de mentir aux
gens
c'est ça mais tu vois Booba ce qui est
en train de faire c'est
c'était tellement nécessaire c'est
tellement nécessaire de bien marquer une
différence aussi entre les gens qui ont
travaillé pour avoir leur communauté
ceux sur lequel c'est le travail de
plusieurs années ceux qui vont sortir
juste d'un télé-crochet attention j'ai
pas que c'est pas du travail mais parce
que je pense que c'est des sacrés
tournages tu vois mais ceux qui vont
sortir d'un télé-crochet et qui d'un
coup vont avoir une masse d'audience qui
va arriver qui ne sait pas construire
sur des années donc du coup il y a
peut-être moins aussi ce rapport en
disant c'est des vrais gens parce que
moi ça m'a pris du temps à me rendre
compte peut-être que ne sont pas encore
rendu compte du coup se permettent de
faire la promotion de produits qui sont
plus douteux que d'autres mais je trouve
ça génial que Booba mais je trouve ça
même ouf que cette
colonie cette conversation arrive grâce
à Booba franchement
la piraterie quoi donc bravo à lui
d'avoir mis la lumière sur ça et je
pense que le l'État va commencer
vraiment aussi apprendre ça très au
sérieux parce que quand il y a des
jeunes qui se font arnaquer quand ils se
font
influencer pour acheter des produits qui
sont dangereux mais des vrais produits
dangereux je te parle pas de
d'un vêtement je te parle de produits
qui vont te faire maigrir mais en fait
qui vont juste te détruire l'estomac ces
produits que tu vas t'appliquer sur la
peau mais qui ont des compositions
complètement étranges enfin c'est quand
même
moi c'est l'heure de la base et toi pour
l'initiative de Booba justement je
rebondis dessus parce que justement
enthousiaste c'était important qui est
quelqu'un qui a un formulaire oui mais
je pense que l'État nous on le voit
c'est de plus en plus
contrôlée légiférer et c'est ce qu'il
fallait c'est que
c'est une activité extra-scolaire pour
beaucoup maintenant ça devient un vrai
métier et il faut qu'on soit tous cadrer
réguler
sur ce job comme tous les autres Jobs tu
vois alors qui dit fin d'interview dit
aussi de parler bah on a parlé de 2022
de l'anxiété début 2023 de tes rêves
aussi et c'est quoi un peu tes projets
là pour cette année là qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui va se passer bientôt
qu'est-ce qu'on va voir si tu as envie
ce serait bien bon projet je trouve
franchement si je peux continuer à créer
du contenu et de divertir des gens je
suis gagnante peu importe la plateforme
récemment je me suis
lancée sur le Podcast c'était je pense
le format qui me manquait un format plus
long ou tu peux rentrer beaucoup plus en
profondeur sur certains sujets tu vois
on parle de l'anxiété par exemple c'est
des sujets c'est difficile de d'aborder
dans une story de 15 secondes ou sur une
vidéo YouTube on essaye un peu de
ramener plus de légèreté de lumière
du coup c'est vrai que le podcast le
fait déjà que
tu te retrouves seul face à un micro
c'est dans une position très vulnérable
et si tu acceptes de faire d'exercice tu
le fais avec une réelle envie de créer
une conversation et donc le podcast
canapé 6 places c'était vraiment quelque
chose
quand j'ai fait le premier épisode je me
suis dit mais waouh pourquoi j'ai pas
fait ça plutôt pourquoi je me suis pas
mis à cet exercice plutôt et puis ce qui
est génial c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
essaie de mélanger des conversations
solo et des conversations avec des
invités j'ai eu le grand honneur de
recevoir plein d'invités géniaux très
talentueux mais tous diversifié si tu
vois c'est pas juste une youtubeuse qui
va interviewer des youtubeurs vraiment
on sort un peu de ce spectre parce que
le format du podcast fait que on a tous
un petit peu envie de parler tu sais
quand arrive sur un plateau télé je sais
pas si vous avez mais le temps de parole
est chronométrer tu as le droit à 4
minutes tu viens pour promouvoir un
projet donc du coup c'est c'est assez
mode auto-pilote alors que sur le
Podcast tu peux te permettre de de
converser comme là on le fait je sais
même pas si ça vous intéresse mais si
c'est génial justement parce que ce qui
est ce qui plaisant et moi je sais aussi
en tant que journaliste ou ça m'arrive
des fois on me dit bah tu as 15 minutes
pour faire une interview ouais c'est dur
frustrant tu es là tu as ta feuille tu
as même pas fait le les deux tiers qu'on
dit bon bah c'est fini c'est dur et puis
c'est fortement des bons moments que je
passe et ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
c'est que il y a des choses qu'on
changeait dans ma vie depuis que je fais
des vidéos j'ai rencontré beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui sont tellement
intéressants et généreux ça peut être
des acteurs ça peut être des chanteurs
ça peut être des auteurs et en fait
c'est conversation là quand je l'ai vu
je me dis
c'est des choses à ancrer dans le temps
c'est des choses à partager parce que
quand je rencontre
une Géraldine Nakache qui qui est maman
qui va te donner des conseils remplis de
bienveillance d'amour ou un pierliné qui
va te raconter comment il s'est
complètement désinhibé du regard des
gens tu dis mais ça c'est des choses qui
qui moi m'ont vraiment touché
profondément qui m'ont marqué et qui
seront des changements dans ma vie j'ai
envie de le partager donc c'est comme ça
que on a le podcast aussi avec les
invités petite question qui revient
souvent alors j'ai pas demandé ton avis
sur la réforme des retraites mais ça me
fait quand même rebondir une question si
tu la vois à quel âge la tienne ma
retraite
j'ai pas de juste milieu c'est soit
l'année prochaine soit dans 75 ans à 75
ans carrément ouais moi je suis scorpion
c'est tout ça fera plaisir
je peux comptabiliser des heures en plus
pour vous si vous voulez
c'est pas mal vous voulez j'en prends ça
me dérange pas on a parlé des petits
trucs compliqués mais j'imagine si tu
avais un petit mot pour 2023 pour pour
tous ceux qui te suivent au quotidien
qui tombent beaucoup d'amour aussi tous
les jours
ça va faire je crois ma cinquième année
exposée je suis sûre vous en avez marre
de voir ma gueule moi aussi mais si vous
êtes resté jusqu'à la fin de cette vidéo
c'est que on partage un petit bout de
2023 ensemble merci de suivre mes
aventures merci de suivre ce drôle de
métier et toutes les réflexions qui vont
avec et je suis particulièrement
reconnaissante cette année tu as envie
de commencer en me disant c'est fou ce
que je vis et j'ai envie d'être digne de
l'amour que l'on me donne et de cette
plateforme qu'on m'a donné et qu'est-ce
qu'on peut se poser
une sieste